les gens croient vouloir la richesse le
pouvoir mais ce n'est pas là ils veulent
simplement sentir que leur vie compte
que eux ils comptent
cette baisse de salaire ben affleck de
largement temporaires par luo béria
regardez les ils attendent tous alors
qu'elle traverse
[Applaudissements]
laissez-nous campé sur nos terres chacun
est retranché dans son camp et personne
ne fera pas vers l'autre cette balle est
organisé trois hommes se partagent la
totalité des terres les oblige on oublié
titre doit j'ai travaillé cette grève et
je vous prie je regarde moi vous êtes de
la blâmer le gouverneur n'a pas eu
d'autre solution que de réquisitionner
la garde nationale ils vont jusqu'à mais
on va résister à ça
mon père aussi étaient nuls ces prêts
une décharge de thirteen antenne
poitrine parce qu'il avait eu le culot
de révolte et de dire qu'on traitait mal
alors on est petit on est ce qu'ils vont
changer tout ça s'ils ont livré une
bataille n 4 a retrouvé toute tentative
de résistance sera combattue avec la
plus grande fermeté
maintenant ils vous ont triché comme des
rats alors qui est avec moi
on a tort le bateau ivoire
que je veux c'est voir une vidéo
[Musique]
on voit le pays frère
on essaie de changer les choses pour des
millions de personnes